i tell my staff all the time and some of
them are here that we have done our job
when we leave the audience wanting more
that's the true mark of a great
conversation when you leave the audience
wanting more you talked about
wanting more wanting more i don't know
how that works
for film and score but it leads me to
ask this two-part exit question
for any film that you will ever score
for the rest of your life or have ever
scored
number one what is it that you want the
audience to have as they take away the
is the takeaway that they leave wanting
more that or something i'm missing what
is the takeaway you want the audience to
have
i know what the answer is when they
leave
the the la field i mean when you're
scoring a film what do you want them to
leave with number one
and number two tell me anything i don't
want to color this too much tell me
anything i want to box you in
anything about your life
that most informs the way you approach
your work
as
a film score
with the feel that i wrote the music
just
i don't know because it will be too much
ego to say what i want for the people to
live
to go because
it's it's a teamwork you know and it's
the most important thing at the end
is the image that you see
and
and as a musician
how you touch that
how you don't
you don't destroy it
the beauty
because at the end it's about beauty
the risk
so
it's very
personal
particular and this is the good thing of
this i would love that the people live
you know
feeling what they feel
at the end it's like in a concert it's
like in a concert you know
you you are sad and you end happy you
are happy and you ain't sad you have
this kind of different
emotions different feelings that the
live art create
and
and especially in a film i'm sorry you
know
with john here in gustavo
i was trying
not to disturb
do not disturb
you know i put that in the door
from the beginning that i started to
write
do don't disturb do not disturb so the
thing is to help
that image
to go to move
to move because it's time
and
about life
i don't know
everything
um
i love life
you know and
in particular
i
i try to live every moment
in a very intense way
with intensity
with intensity no no not with tension we
have moments with tensions we have
moments relaxed but always have to be
very intense and it's only at the end as
i know as we know is only one life that
we live
so
since
i was born until now
something particular i don't know
the music
is the music
it's the music that moved me to do
things and
and i remember when i was a teenager
going to the cinema
to watch films with friends
and we were so inspired about that
especially listening to the music
and how
how one note
can change i remember one day
one friend of mine
he was called by a
company of a film company
to
rewrite
the music of a film
the film was a comedy
but the producers they didn't want to
have a comedy
was a drama
but the music
was so funny
that the film
was a comedy
so
they were like can you do something with
that because we need a drama with this
movie so
he
wrote
the complete music and then was a
complete different feeling so what an
amazing thing
you know
every note
every simple note
that john
put
you know in a score
is a universe
it's like mallard
every note is an universe and that notes
will give to us
what we want to feel
and
at the end this is the power of
what we do